hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
today we're looking at a few different
things starting off with Mars Attacks
the goofiest aliens you'll ever see but
also very interestingly made because
they are creepy
seriously the ones you walk oh so creepy
also we're gonna look at some really
cool microscope photography that's gonna
blow your mind this is crazy this isn't
CGI right let me finally listen to the
comments Shin Godzilla is in this
episode do you think you know Godzilla
you've seen some Godzillas Shin Godzilla
is quite different and very special I
can't wait until we get to see elbow
Godzilla Godzilla
[Music]
I suspect I have more to fear from us
and move from them back in 1996 there
was a big attack from
oh yeah I know
so tough to get things looking real like
this not a bad job though I was about to
say it was like considering it's 1996 I
feel like they did a pretty decent job
so the major effects in this movie were
done by two different Studios ilm and
Warner digital which was like a brand
new company at the time and Warner took
care of all the spaceships while ilm did
most of the aliens
look at that secondary motion cheek
dangles the cheek dangles dangle dang
originally this was supposed to be a
stop-motion movie the aliens were at
least supposed to be a stop motion to
begin with and as they were getting
going and they started doing some tests
they had a problem because all of the
aliens had those glass domes over their
head and it was reflecting all of the
armatures and whatnot and at a certain
point they kind of realized we might as
well just do the entire alien CG but
they wanted to maintain some of that
sort of stop-motion aesthetic they made
an attempt to try to make all of the
animations a little bit more like
juttery a little bit to kind of make the
Martians seem a little bit creepier and
they had a facial animation system at
the time but most of the expression that
we're seeing is just based off of moving
these little balls in these sockets for
the eyeballs
what's really cool here is that the set
of these UFOs the Interiors are
stop-motion sets they're miniature sets
oh cool they had a really really
interesting motion control system that
they called scan to move so they were
able to get these shots through the
miniature UFO and it automatically
kicked out a digital camera so they
didn't have to do any match moving at
all it was just like all right we moved
the camera and we have a file associated
with it nice which is something that I
don't see that often we're starting to
see a Resurgence of that these days with
like using iPhones to automatically
track stuff these shots are more
impressive between the desert shots when
it's full CG characters like this like
it actually looks really solid and I'm
not distracted by the human beings
interacting with cartoon characters like
this feels like a cohesive scene like
I'm my disbelief is being suspended yeah
well it's also just like it's a better
setting too where you have more control
with your lighting it's like the
ultimate test of anything that CGI is
put it out in direct sunlight and see
how it looks
[Music]
[Applause]
freaking woman who was a Martian and was
just very scary looking the way she
walked just like all smoothly creeped me
out for years it's just seriously the
way she walks so creepy okay so it's
this next shot apparently the hardest
shot in the entire movie was this one
foreign
the hole through the cheek the whole
time as it goes up yeah right it's high
level so they initially tried to use the
tool that they developed for Terminator
2 called make sticky which is
essentially just projection mapping but
really early days and it couldn't quite
work the way like her lips are
distorting the way you kind of see the
relief of the brain underneath her skin
see is that a still though like are they
projecting a still image and using that
just as like I think so I think they're
doing some sort of like projection
Distortion type thing but dude check it
out like at the top the Shadows move no
the eyes of the yeah of the Mask move oh
wow what you see that yeah I did it's
really subtle but it helps it not feel
totally fake you know like it makes it
feel like it's a practical head being
held even though it's probably just what
like a composite like they get a plate
here of the woman pulling the head up
and then like a second plate of just the
head for the texture so I don't think
she's lifting her head off at all look
at her fans they're comped onto that
hair yeah like you can kind of see a
little bit of that fake contact Shadow
her pinky kind of disappears into the
hair the moment she touches it the hair
doesn't deform at all yes a different
head element she's just going like that
with nothing in her hands for sure
exactly yeah there's some actually
there's some really like interesting
subtle things happening that aren't like
the main effect for example watch the
hands and the forearms of the woman we
watch as they stretch and distort oh to
make the motion work for going around
the brain because the actress didn't do
that perfectly necessarily you know also
the scale of it yeah she's having to
like take the whole thing way off the
top of her head and so instead of having
her arms like this they're actually like
this but elongated yeah the other crazy
thing is the relief of the skull and the
Brain underneath as the heads has to go
up you don't see the shading and the
shading fades in it's very subtle but to
suddenly give it the definition of the
skull underneath all they can do is just
fade which is probably just a
two-dimensional image of like the
Shadows because they don't have like
hyper crazy CG stuff you know back then
it works really well though like the end
results of that effort right there you
clearly see the alien head underneath it
and it achieves that effect yep yeah
this is a shot where it's like you have
the main effect and there's like a
thousand other effects around it that
you have to do first just to make it
work there's apparently always a shot in
every movie that like kills the person
working on it and this was that shot
Mars Attacks I've been wanting to look
at it for a long time and here we are so
this is this is just mind this is
mind-blowing look at this watch this
[Music]
foreign
oh I know this account though absolutely
yes yeah this is crazy this isn't CGI
right there's like lots of quote-unquote
VFX going on but there's no way this is
no because this is this is the count
that space specializes in macro
photography and robot arm stuff so
they're able to get incredibly precise
camera moves is it a robotic arm what
might be the case for these shots is
that they're very very meticulously
placed and they're filming pretty wide
and they're cropping in and doing all
the camera animation in post yeah like
what I'm seeing here is I'm seeing a
multiple versions stitched together
exactly but that like that's the
creative VFX part of this which is like
yes there's incredible stuff that you're
seeing like that's totally real but at
the same time in order to kind of film
it in such a stylized manner we have to
use those paint out techniques and
tricks of camera motion to make it feel
even more impossible it's just really
really in cinematography if it's one
person making these shots they clearly
have a great understanding of
cinematography using a camera and macro
lenses along with visual effects for all
the transitions but I think they also
have an eye for animation being able to
animate the camera with very smooth
transitions in and out it's fun seeing
things that you take for granted if
you're really tiny and slow this is what
the world would look like
[Music]
what does Shin mean I don't know a lot
of people have requested or suggested
that we take a look at Shin Godzilla
I've seen that yeah and I was like all
right I've written down my list I went
to check it out and I was blown away so
we've seen a lot of Godzilla movies
these days but this immediately felt
different this is a Japanese film it's a
Japanese film
that shot's 100 CG right by the way yeah
all of it all of it wait how old is this
movie I think it came out like two or
three years ago 2018. all that city is
CG you're saying yep no way but not the
not the background there is it look at
the detail in that background though
like right to the right of this building
as we clear it look at all that that
looks real to me on the right oh my
goodness it is yeah that's wild Bravo
it's pretty nice no they okay they did
track in some some real plate in the
distance there though but the stuff I
was looking at was CG I think Godzilla
isn't real I know he's not real he's a
metaphor
they're all getting head shots dude the
Japanese guy is so gnarly looking yeah
he looks like he's really crustacean is
that a real Godzilla so visual effects
they actually did a bunch of cool stuff
there is a CG Godzilla in this a lot of
these shots are CG Godzilla's but a lot
of these shots are actually animatronics
and puppets filmed on a blue screen of a
giant godzilla and okay yeah like they
have a CGI Godzilla that actually looks
great and like inner Cuts with the
animatronic one perfectly and I like
that they made the cg1 look like the
animatronic one as opposed to making the
animatronic look like the CG yeah that's
the baby Yoda approach yep it works
great it feels like they almost just
moved the puppet and like filmed it and
just animated to that when I saw this it
immediately jumped out to me how
different it was won the cinematography
and the approach to this is so much
different it's much more like tiny toys
fighting a giant very slow monster
that's a monster and its proportions are
weird its face is weird it doesn't have
humanistic expressions or Angry Eyebrows
or anything like that it is truly like a
grotesque mutated creature and the
reason it's red and black Wren is
because it's constantly mutated and
growing like oh it's not like it's a
lizard that's big it's like a flesh mass
of mutation that's like in constant pain
[Music]
these explosions and Sims are pretty
solid too yeah well they they actually
use a lot of Miniatures there's a lot of
stuff in this we're like you know what
CG animation can kind of look cool let's
just do it with Miniatures let's treat
it like an art form let's shoot it
beautifully let's get some really cool
stuff with Miniatures that would either
be incredibly hard to do a CGI or just
looks delightful when it's a miniature
now you want to see something cool
around I would love to see something
cool
whoa
oh wait the the matting on that was
interesting was that the blue screen it
might have been Godzilla but with a
liquid Sim on it probably
oh he's got another jaw what's he about
to do is he gonna shoot lasers out of
his mouth at the ground to blow up the
whole city
so cool whoa
okay that's pretty sweet that's a good
use of a Sim all those buildings like
curl the smoke around
I love it
[Music]
that one plane
longest lightsaber
yes it's like super sick but kind of
can't be at the same time oh wow that
that was sick that's pretty cool going
through all the buildings
oh
wow
[Music]
Bravo it's a little campy at times but
then it like immediately switches to a
super legit shot and then back to kind
of a campy shot yeah it's Godzilla it's
like it's truly Godzilla like this is a
Godzilla movie it's not an American
movie with monsters pretending to be a
Godzilla movie like this is a Godzilla
move pillow it's getting so many points
for just being different that you're
like whoa this is fresh this is crazy
and I like it and it's effective too
yeah interesting ready to play
[Applause]
Wish Master he's back
we're back
let me get a cup of water wait
was this like the one that starts out in
like Egypt or whatever yeah
and and Chase cut it from the main route
like it's in the extended episodes It's
not actually on YouTube so I want this
to make it a whole separate world of
react that everyone on YouTube doesn't
know about as Sam said there's a whole
world of react that if you're only on
YouTube you've been missing so check it
on quarterdigital.com but today that
world is coming to YouTube well we'll
see Chase gets to this no we're deciding
right now so just a real little recap
here main character is the genie guy
he's always monkey paw on his way around
he can only do something if somebody
asks him to do it so he's always trying
to like manipulate the situation I have
to get
well now you'd have to go through me and
that is something I would love to see
ooh the wish Master look
[Laughter]
[Music]
s
Katie was so cool and then once it was
always gonna be cool it was so close to
being cool oh man I was like the scenes
actually kind of it seems kind of
working I'm kind of into the scene this
is funny because he's like I want you to
leave yeah and he's like he's like
it's good it's like actually cool and
then
oh no
and then what is what is the last part
here it's like okay walks through
it and then just
why does it have to hit the
front of is this one
I mean this is cool too it's kind of
gruesome it's gruesome I guess he's
getting pancaked in the glass what flips
me out is that like this he was facing
the other way and now he's facing this
way is his face just on both sides of
him now yeah yeah yeah
you go to see a stained glass window
it's not like the back of Jesus on one
side of my friends on the other fair
I was just assuming he got squished into
that there should still be some but I
guess he got converted into a stained
glass man all right no which mess is
good that was great yeah until next time
wish Master it was great
so I discovered Wishmaster because of
the comments so please leave a
suggestion down below I just I haven't
seen every movie it's impossible but I
would like to try so yeah throw down
some bangers some things that you think
people haven't seen that are visually
awesome I have seen every movie